crab feast you know what it's all about
this is the crab feast I'm yelling [ __ ]
that you ain't gotta ask me cuz you
could trust that every Tuesday you
already know though Orion's like the
soccer star JUCO above ground crew goes
better than most Jay Larson
self-diagnose go download this week last
week here we go again [ __ ] the crab
feast
[Music]
yeah welcome back to the crab feast
y'all circle dot to what else man oh no
the crappy for that ass oh man that's
the first titled over knocked out of a
[ __ ] I don't believe felt like if we
didn't let that could have gone on
forever I mean now I was ready to go
away uh good to be here with you buddy
great to be here with you too and great
to be here with all you guys Jay Larson
over Jay Larson comic con trai lots in
common in all social media I just want
to say a huge thank you to everyone that
came out to my taping of a special at
the El Rey it was fantastic I was
humbled to have that many people there
and humbled to have the response that I
got and it just means a lot to have you
guys in my life and I just really
appreciate it and I'm looking forward to
hopefully getting it somewhere out soon
so that you guys can watch it at home
that weren't able to be there so that's
it for me sickle cell Ryan Sickler on
Twitter Instagram Ryan Sickler official
Facebook Ryan Sickler com I just want to
tell you that I am sincerely and
seriously proud of you like what you
pulled off is no short feet I know what
you had to do that I know I must go
today but it was fantastic uh crab feast
calm where you get all your merch got
the all juco shirts available up there
now great in time for Christmas how many
times I gotta say it come on you're all
juco show the world on and please please
use our amazon link for your holiday
Chimene you got please do your holiday
shopping quit waiting on that man we've
been telling you for weeks now well
listen up we have some great sponsors
this week and there are a lot of them
but it's that time of year you know it
means the holiday shopping everyone's
get it done there's these sponsorships
help us keep the podcasts free to you
guys and at the same time it offers you
guys some great deals to maybe make your
holiday shopping a little bit easier or
make your life a little bit easier a
little more fun Liz something here for
everybody so give these a listen first
up Harry's calm great shaving product
from Harry's we've mentioned them before
Harry's was sired by two best friends
Jeff and Andy who are fed up with some
evidence
sup place being overcharged for razor so
they start their own razor company to
give people what they deserve a great
shave at a fair price we've talked about
it before it's ridiculous how much you
pay for raises in the store uh this is a
great gift to give to give it to a
husband you give it to a wife you write
to a son too late daughter ladies
daughters to man yeah anyone you need
I've used it rise used it they they're
shaving cream is got it's almost like
spa like you know you feel like you're
at a spa which is the thing that I like
most about it it's got to cut the razors
are beautifully done the handle is done
and this love that razor I'd say another
time man I'm telling you I mean it's
stupid but the weight to it is just you
know to me ever like a knife that's got
like a heavy weight or like darts you
know what I mean I just like a
heavyweight man and that's what this
one's got right now Harry's limit
edition set special offer from us to you
this holiday Harry is offering a limited
edition shaving set midnight blue chrome
razor handle which you can get engraved
which is dope three of Harry's
german-engineered five blade cartridge
that provide a close comfortable shave
beautifully designed gift box foaming
shave gel that smells amazing all this
goes for thirty dollars calm that's a
great gift also offer handles and sets
starting at just 10 bucks additional if
you tried harry's for the first time so
fans of the show you guys we've
partnered with harry's to give you five
dollars off your order when you enter
code crab at checkout and if you order
before december ninth you can also get
free shipping go to Harry's calm right
now and get limited edition holiday
shave set while supplies last and don't
forget to enter code crab at checkout
for five dollars off tell you about it
every week lost my name one of my
favorite gifts to give if you have
children in your life it's the perfect
go-to gift from newborn on every story
is unique to the letters in your child's
name you can get one for every kid in
the home lost my name is the perfect
Christmas gift for any boy or girl they
have hand-drawn illustrations on every
page that bring the personalized book to
life it's made by you for your child so
you literally sit there online and you
click and you build this book you pick
the characters they meet
pick the story that you're going to go
through i read estella every night and
now she's starting to memorize this
thing about to get a new one play each
child can follow the letters of their
name through the book to discover the
story is all about them it's more
magical than a typical personalized book
that simply insert the child's name
throughout a generic story it's a great
personalized gift for baby showers
birthdays or like I said the holidays go
to www aust my name that's lost my dot
name and enter your little one's name
for a free preview of their story later
right out for you'll be able to see
exactly what it's going to look like
enter code crab feast and get ten
percent off your order shipping is free
worldwide order now in time for
Christmas that's wws 3 w's loss my name
today and during the holiday season
everybody's eating it's wintertime
you're bundled up everybody wants to
cook at home just after Thanksgiving
last week it was Sunday night we had
eaten through all the leftovers were
tied a turkey and Kate was like what are
we gonna do and I'm like I go I don't
want to go anywhere she's like me either
we didn't want to order in and I had the
Omaha Steaks and reads he loves when I
get him steak so I cooked up some filet
mignon so we had in there yes filet he
had falutin we crushed steak at home
thanks to Omaha steak and it was
fantastic leo some potatoes like rotten
and then those are Apple tartlets that
we had for like a little dessert which
kept him up a little extra than i wanted
but what can you do oh mistakes is
amazing product over 500 gourmet gift
ideas at the site highest quality cuts
and ingredients one-of-a-kind flavor
convenient quick shopping for those on
your list age for 21 days to unlock the
full flavor of the cuts hand trimmed
vacuum-sealed online recipes wine
pairings and much much more for this
gift this year right now oh mah stakes
is giving an exclusive savings just to
our listeners listen everything you get
450 bucks 4999 the Jay Larson discount
that's seventy-seven percent off
seventy-seven percent of two filet
mignons to top sirloins two boneless
pork chops for chicken breast for
kielbasa sausage is four burgers 12
ounce package of beef meatballs
folktales la grande for caramel apple
tarts those are slamming one Omaha
Steaks season packets and for additional
cabas is why
you rock and two farms go to Omaha you
don't get too far go to Omaha that's how
much food it is we get it right Hank go
to Omaha Steaks calm enter our code crab
feast in the search bar that's important
in the search bar add the family gift
pack to your car gets seventy-seven
percent savings it's the gift guaranteed
to be a hit guaranteed to be a hit all
these gifts are hits another great gift
a beautiful watch from movement holiday
shopping seasons here with movement you
can skip the crowds and standing in the
crazy lines at the mall and find a gift
that they'll love at prices that beat
the department stores movement watches
start at just $95 alright at a
department store the same watch four to
five hundred bucks we say it all the
time movement figured out that by
selling online they were able to cut out
the middleman and retail markup
providing the best possible price their
classic design quality construction and
style minimalism JS got that fat gold
one I got a nice gun metal one and I jam
Josh out of Myers has one now I'm sure
does over 500,000 watches sold in over
160 countries there it's a quality
product I love wearing mine I get
compliments every time and here's what
you can do right now you get fifteen
percent off today with free shipping and
free returns alright so if you don't
like it boom goes right back by going to
movement watches dot-com / crab that's
mvmt watches calm / crab this watch has
a really clean design it feels great on
your wrist and now is the time to step
up your watch game just in time for the
holidays go to mvmt watches calm / crab
and join the movement so at Halloween I
went to a Halloween party with the kids
and all my couple buddies they were
there with their kids and my buddy comes
over and he's all dressed up and like on
the Latin costume with this kid he goes
what dude you're the cool dad you don't
wear a costume I'm like yeah man I'm
really wear costumes like oh got to be
the cool dad huh and I was like yeah so
now to hear prints I got my tipsy elves
they rock out the ugly sweaters and I'm
gonna go to the ugly sweater party and
I'm gonna come correct because they made
me feel like a jackass for not having
anything and I don't want to be that dad
who's like oh yeah I'm too cool for my
kids so
everyone needs an ugly Christmas sweater
this time of year if you want bragging
rights for the most talked-about sweater
at your Christmas party listen up tipsy
elves has hundreds of Christmas sweaters
designs that are like nothing you ever
seen before it's not like you just have
some horrible ugly like tons of
snowflakes on it the one that I have I
mentioned it before is reindeers having
sex with each other and it's so subtle
you would never notice unless you look
down getting it up on it you gotta like
look okay the not for the faint of heart
they have tons of different things check
out all new sweaters 2016 sweaters you
won't find them anywhere else and
they're incredibly well-made they're not
like these trashy things you're gonna
get at some thrift store they're super
warm and comfy while shopping for a new
sweater check out other holiday and
collegiate attire for your holiday or as
a gift like adult onesies which one
hundred percent i said adult onesies for
men interactive sweaters beer pong
cornhole and Christmas suits that's a
suit for women holiday legging sweaters
dresses pajamas right now our listeners
get twenty percent off tipsy elves calm
on anything they order on the site shop
now for the best selection choose from
and have it in time for your holiday
Christmas party go to tipsy elves calm
and drive code crab at checkout for
twenty percent off sitewide christmas is
less than three weeks away ah like it
less than three weeks it's like 18 days
I think left the shop wrap and deliver
your gift so choose a gift from shari's
berries incredible collection of gifts
and go ahead and skip the crowds and the
hassle altogether you know we do them
every holiday freshly dipped
strawberries from shari's berries
starting at just 19 99 that's over
thirty percent savings or double the
berries right now for just ten bucks
more you need our code to take advantage
of this deal the code is crab CR a B I
it's an incredible unique gift that's
perfect for sharing even though they may
not want to and these things are huge
they're huge you get to choose and
here's the other thing you get to choose
the delivery day and shari's berries
will deliver your gift fresh and on time
guaranteed all right there and they have
more than just berries they've added new
seasonal treats just in time for the
holidays so with Christmas right around
the corner there's only one way to get
this amazing 1999 shari's berries deal
and
help support the show just visit berries
calm that's berr IES dot com click on
the microphone in the top right hand
corner and type in crab shari's berries
has something for everyone and every
taste go to Barry's calm click on the
microphone and type in crab today
excited to have back you know a man king
of the black palace welcome back to crab
feasts here for the Christmas episode
series alone I got up to the ground by
the crab please see some oh come on it
I'm already having fun you guys made me
feel special rating of the black Palace
man forever forever the king of the bike
out how many DJ's can mix off a one
turntable just yeah buddy that's why
they call you the king uh it is so good
to sit here next to you and see your
smiling face it's so good to have you
back you know what we do here why don't
before we get into anything why don't
you go ahead and plug your Twitter your
social media your your CD or whatever
you want give a new CD out out called
what's up nerds sup nerd what's up nerds
like about like when you're cool wicked
and you think you're so cool and you're
like what's up nerds because you know
I'm not one of you I'm obviously not a
nerd but at the same time it's like
you're still like yeah what's up nerds
like I'm still talking to you but yeah
yeah yeah I still do as an adult but
I'll do to my friends of mine sup losers
yeah I do it all the time whenever I
walk into a room I'm like sup nerds yeah
I'm just kidding guys I was just job
guys jashin Gino is funny I did that
once in somebody you could tell was like
they're like i am not a nerd I'm like oh
I hit a sore I'm buddy I'm joking around
I taking it wasn't recently cuz you want
to be a nerd nowadays it's the coolest
thing ever um wait where'd you record it
I recorded at the La Jolla Comedy Store
la jolla yet no edits just one show I
just like the way que me know when
someone says no edits they definitely
added god it's been it's been mixed more
times than metallic black out Bob rock
is gonna be like with the horn headphone
on and cut to the ice cream bit and
action whoa
haha yeah there's I'm nota no bad words
at all on it completely squeaky clean
that's great that's great for Pandora
and everything yeah plus it's like
there's so many more comedy fans now
because of podcast so many dads listen
to these and they're like I want
something I can listen to with my kids
it's not stinky listen our podcast with
their kids if they do they cut they got
it out there like are you get out of
your name touch of [ __ ] and get the
hell out well you know it's great a lot
of dads have told me like cuz my first
album had three bad words on it and uh a
lot of dads are like I I let him listen
to it yeah it's like right it's like he
was like I kind of like that was a
little edgy one of my favorite stories
of a ride with his dad is when you
caught him or found him watching Richard
Pryor right yeah much and busting loose
that's how it's what that's what was the
birth of comedy for me because I had
snuck down and I saw kids on TV and I
was like oh mama kid i can probably
watch this it ended up being he's taking
the best thought that was my process
probably why i should be able to watch
this there's children in it and then i
started laughing and that's how i got
busted he act like he was mazey get in
here and he was like yeah we get that
get your ass in here and then let me sit
sit down and watch with me now that's
the greatest story of how was it but i
didn't real bad but you know at the end
of the movie rides dad died the end of
his movie well when you said know what I
was honestly thinking of watching Chris
Rock i remember in a me myself and irene
where he's got the three kids yeah Chris
wrong yeah remember at the beginning you
see Jim Carrey watching Richard Pryor
with his three solid right we got a
judge absolutely right yeah and then it
cuts to watching Chris Rock twenty years
later and he's like that's a funny
mother effort yeah so good well my dad
was my dad that's the only one like and
then he pulled me out of bed to to watch
SNL Eddie Murphy do mr. Robinson's
neighborhood my birth on to that that
was like six or 7th grade yeah and it
makes it more fun when you got outta bed
yet oh yes easy qualify what's going on
at this hour of the night pass and then
it just became very much like Eddie
Murphy raw when they were all doing the
talent show in front of the old family
members and I got up and did the monkey
and he kicked him in the ding ding and
they all died there's
on one uncle's laughs at everybody else
I'll Jack's not yet fast and he started
to doing yeah I'm a minute Bing so you
recorded always got town it sounds good
that was from what well that's like the
beginning of all forever back to 80
specials they stabbed like a little
vignette yeah I there were my favorite
drummer the one for dice like and
Roseanne Carter don't wear no panties
not every doesn't wear any panties so
doesn't work that's how I correct so
good alright so you've got the new CD
out what's all that record in La Jolla
yeah one of my favorite rooms such a
great room and I love San Diego in
general it's a great call me town it
fast and then Don Carlos taco shop right
across oh yeah well right now he's the
great if he is the best that's great man
that your your 2nd CD or first second
one yeah second one yeah so I learned
from the first one like I said there was
three bad words and I don't know if you
died he had about 12 to 13 bad jokes wow
that's gonna be on everything I pea
shooter but do you ever like even if
it's not bad words you say stuff cuz
like like okay this one I'm just getting
over as a comic I'm just saying what i
want to say instead of trying to like
like I would say uh words like so people
would like think I was cool or something
you know like to sort of i keep the
audience's attention and like i used to
use f bomb strategically if I felt like
I was not holding their attention or it
start to and another thing I did
deliberately in the cds i slowed down
man yeah i probably did 90 minutes worth
of material in 60 minutes on the first
CD cuz i just wanted to keep on crushing
and i think it works great in the room
but the lesson I learned was when you
record a CD it's not as much about the
room as it is for the listener at home
they want a process yes you gotta slow
it down a little bit and I did that on
the CD and I'm proud of it yeah it's
good about doing that with this
[ __ ] intro right
take our in the morning of the black um
how are you good also promote your
social media your podcast yeah podcasts
got good times i just did at world class
episode with larson promoters you're a
baby i need to get you back on there bro
i would love been too long i would love
because since you been gone since you
put the caffeine is kicking in ah my
websites awesome Steve calm there's a
link to my podcast good times on there
and then my social media is just a
Twitter's at Steve's mom Steve's mom
common and that CD the CDs out right now
people can go grab it yeah it's on
iTunes Amazon all that stuff and then
last night I just ordered physical
copies of the CD and this is the best
the kid my buddy Ryan made the cover
look like a pizza box but with my face
on it all night like that like the chef
now Holden well I wanted to publish F
had what he did one where you found the
body and it was a chubby little body
holding out the people you like that and
it says what's up nerds and then it's
like instead of like hot and fresh pizza
it's like clean and funny comedy you've
delivered fret whatever but my friendly
figured out a way to make the CD itself
look like a pepperoni pizza oh that's
time cools that degree and then the back
of it is a sweet Cobra what's better
than pizzas and I will say something
about Steve Simone's comedy is when you
see it you I don't care what kind of
mood you're in you're gonna leave
feeling good about yourself about life
and about man kind of like gym trying oh
it's super infections I've said for a
long time you're like human prozac you
really are you make everything better oh
um have something in my eye well right
before you take care of that I want you
give your shoutout out there we do
Twitter hey hey play a shout out I love
that because just the other night it was
headlining irvine improv they called
last minute on a sunday and was like yes
and this guy dan savage his twitter is
at zip watcher z IP wa TC h er and he
saw me years ago open up for run is easy
in cleveland and he was like I'm out
here on vacation I got the wife we got a
sitter
home and I was like yeah I love making
dads laughs oh it's my favorite thing is
family laughs yeah it's the best so when
family guys come out and see me do
comedy it's my end there was moms in the
audience I do a whole Biddle moms on the
CD because I don't get enough credit and
then all the moms liked me afterwards
made me feel good because it may be feel
like they knew my mom or something it's
too bad you know the CD to be sewn then
I know but they bought the old one oh
that's great yeah the old home is still
pretty neat there's more to chinese food
on it Lord what it's all about food I
gave my own away just kidding I just got
rid of them because no one has CDs
anymore yeah but people like little
mementos yeah for sure that's why we
sell posters and touching pitches hats
yeah it's the poster cerdo that's Jeff
tice thank you Jeff Jeff tice um hi Jeff
let's get into this story Jeff reached
out to me too he's my friend too because
he heard me on your thing yeah he did he
told us I told you politely shot him
down no I did is that he rejected him he
was crying when he told me I wanna send
him stickers actually have a text from
no please guys notice because he cuz
what member when we were saw and I was
like what what happened I hear this
right here ask you Simone if he wanted
me to do poses form told me wasn't a fan
of my work I'd I'll come on what ya the
business what he had otherwise I say yes
I'll show you one second all what I had
otherwise was perfect for what his brand
is and he said his fans appreciate his
brand is broil oil tea and to be
straight up with you your [ __ ] sucks
dicks right here look at Sunday by the
NBI quotes sticks etc etc it's all here
black and white clear as crystal you
drank fizzy lifting drinks you remember
when Willy Wonka get Charlie the
business you guys just gave me the
business well stick staying with the
family theme that we were already
imagining this is a quite close to a
Christmas episode so it's great to have
you here and use you swear you've got
some Christmas stories for us yeah on
that you would pass a poly I wish they
could see his face out there is he just
a serious yeah so let's hear this
polygraphs story I believe this is
Christmas 1980 guys Christmas Eve or
Christmas Christmas Eve we had recently
moved into a new house oh well la-dee-da
moving up that yeah what is the jiminy
family traditions on Christmas Eve well
we do one gift oh we could open one gift
that was our whole thing growing up one
gift on Christmas Eve okay that's what
makes this story interesting because we
didn't have that I had heard of those
traditions but my house Santa Claus came
and that was it and this was a new house
and your little kid alone is he gonna
know I gotta ask three were there for
like three or four months none of the
gifts under the tree none of them were
no mom and dad every house I'll see we
had I would say 8020 Santa versus mom
dad or whatever I was more like more
like to when it came to mom yeah same as
that 04 that I think I think it's
healthier to have mom and dad gifts
under the tree because as you're a
little kid I'm like what if I mess that
you don't know till Christmas morning a
lot of anxiety in that how Wendy's
mission what do you mean I still kinda a
part of me believes you believe in
Christmas miracles yeah oh for sure I
believe in miracles we'll see what I
liked about it was and I'm doing this I
with my kids to is there'll be three or
four gifts under the tree for a while
for a minute but they're from and you
don't touch them yeah that's yeah and
then summer for other people and you got
to look at them and watch them go that
seems like then the next morning it's
just like you know I don't want to
overdo it but that's when you get all
the gifts that you didn't see but i also
like that because i'm okay with them
because we used to do this we used to
sneak down in the middle of the night
and we would just tear my brother and I
would just tear a little piece of the
back of a gift you got a nerf ball you
know beyond put it back like you got a
[ __ ] Evel Knievel motors ah we will
take them up to our room open them
completely and rewrap know like weeks
before to be stuffing there for my Nana
wrap oh yeah we had our you buy the
paper we had all reread
rapping [ __ ] a rapid station yeah I
almost had a rapid station it's a
Socratic or and I knew my mom hit him in
the my mom would hide gifts in the Attic
the Attic was like a little like crawl
space off of her room and we go in there
and then a Christmas morning we'd all
get up my mom would be exhausted cuz she
was up all night wrapping the Santa
gifts and I remember one morning getting
into my mother's bed jumping on top of
her and peeling her eyes back and
mushrooms like [ __ ] that [ __ ] and she
held him down and I was like wow she's
really out but she stayed up till like
shaking coming down all 9 we were there
like I just good pacing back and coffee
looking at the clock chop chop making
Christmas dinner [ __ ] obviously at the
new house yeah how long had you been in
this house since August this is
Pennsylvania yep and you're now
Christmas Eve yes it's a hole yeah it
was first Christmas in this house and uh
hope you are you all over born at this
point all of us are born and I'm young
enough that I that the concept of
snooping is not looking for presents I
mean I'm waiting on a fat man that is
and this was back like when you can
listen to the radio and they're like
dinging meet Santa Claus his sleigh
scenes flying over Brazil and I'm like I
gotta get to sleep you know because the
rule was he doesn't come to your sleep
he doesn't that's it right that's a
season when you're sleeping he knows
when you're awake totally does no we
should just see cookies right now just
got I picked read up from school today
and the way home I put on like I put on
the radio and start jamming out and he
goes you put on jingle bells daddy oh
cuz they've been singing jingle bells
school and [ __ ] and I'm like oh you get
and then you're just trying to find
jingle bells and it's like different
versions as I give us a new jingle bell
daddy you like the good one daddy that's
got to be so great with kids yeah oh
it's I mean you get to read do it all
over again that's the bar so great yeah
you know what I love about christmas
hinting about gifts with people i can
you just drop it in sort of casual
conversation you know at a fair means
they got those new fair tony hawk
skateboard
that's what I want that's what I want I
keep well give it hell didn't my
favorite thing about Christmas morning
when I got older was my mom explaining
it was it wasn't the gift it was the
story behind the gift there I was right
in the granite run mall and out of the
corner of my eye I saw Fran DeMarco now
you don't remember friend but it wasn't
her mom what are you talking about the
important thing was I saw something
herring I thought maybe it was a
Chewbacca it was Alf and I remembered
how much you love down here was and they
just got them in did the story behind
again then this woman came to grab and I
said [ __ ] my son that's one remember
that woman got stomped for cabbage patch
kid and died like people used to go nuts
every loss tonight somebody out that the
Cabbage Patch loss tonight ours is there
still something like the Furby or the
Cabbage Patch all your face toy but you
don't need to line up for it anymore cuz
you can get it on Amazon used a crab
feast comlink play get it there yeah all
the black friday deals are online to
right and they're all month I don't know
I've never been a big I've never gone
for a sale thing I'm just like what
there I'll find something one cuz we're
all right so it's Christmas Eve yeah and
I'm young enough words all 1980 will you
six six seven years old something like
that and here's the other thing because
we all forget this as adults but when
you're a child you don't have any money
right you have unlimited desires like
when I was six there was always
something I wanted now is it grown up
I'm like I just want quiet could I just
have quiet what is it uncle Steve want
for christmas a nap oh that I'll take a
new pack of socks oh I'll be happy as
[ __ ] with some fresh sauce ok fresh
socks these are my little chica you
intended dan from Forrest Gump I'm fine
oh my god I'd bring them in my car i'll
switch in the middle of the day i once
read that the foo fighters have in there
Ryder fresh socks at every show because
there's nothing they say if it feels
better than putting your feet in the
first for a dollar to every show and you
know what I'm you know my new thing is
to new toothbrushes
for a dollar just feels so good I rocked
I was at the dollar store last night I'm
gonna talk your toothbrush yeah I'm
gonna try this Oh see that's what you do
with kids so when I was just back home I
was visiting with family and she's more
like an aunt but she's really a cousin
but she's well in her 70s and they were
showing me videos and my gram I've seen
I haven't other than photos I haven't
seen my grandmother in a moving picture
so to speak or heard her voice since the
day she died in 1993 yeah and it she was
a little higher pitch than I remembered
yeah at that for a minute to like it had
I to register her voice again cuz it was
slightly different than I heard in my
head but they had old scarves of hers
and little like change purses and all
this and they're sending it to me and I
was like I'm gonna wrap that stuff up
and let her open it at Christmas she
doesn't know the difference between new
and old and she has no idea the concept
of money or any of that and to her the
fun I might be able to buy five gifts
and then let her open up all these other
things because that's what the fun of
Christmas has a rap [ __ ] it's not you
know you play with it for 10 minutes and
anything I'm not [ __ ] putting that
Millennium Falcon Lego [ __ ] together
yeah you're absolutely right there's a
toy store 11 show they think they gift
wrap everything for you and they make it
look magical is that the collectibles
join it like burbank and hazeltine now
no there's a nice little toy store
they're really like old-school [ __ ] you
would love it that's right around the
corner for me go oh is it next to nats a
breakfast place yeah I got it is past
that story wonder Orson yeah that's
exactly where nurse I also notice a
smoke shop right there the same way I
don't smoke grass but I do eat
deliciousness and what I want to play
with naps is great you can go look at
the toys in there at this place called
Karen's toys there's a couple locations
i prefer the encino location actually go
got it right outside so bring that model
playing cuz member and you were a kid
just build way it looked that was part
of the joy of Christmas was seeing the
lights twinkle off the different I and I
always keep these I remember everything
so when I wrap gifts or I get them
wrapped I try to get all different
combinations of paper so it just looks
more magical when I
for me the tree was the most magical
thing in the world radius and I remember
as a kid so like we had it was always in
the living room the tree and those we my
mom had this big red long sofa and the
cushions were thin but they were deep
and there was like wood railings like
armrest were would you know I mean the
year round or was this a holiday so yeah
we have could you imagine bring on the
crane hey get that East Gaddafi's deluxe
II didn't know this was full all year
and right behind that sofa was the
radiator because you know we had those
big steel radiators or whatever they
were all yeah I love the way the smell
when they get to you they knocked and
[ __ ] you know and I Waco's at night time
I never had homework when I was really
young everyone else did and I would just
lay in the couch and stare at the
Christmas tree lit I would love it and I
used to light fires like in the
fireplace all the time even is like a
young kid I would always like mom can
have a fire and chilling all right so I
like we always had a Duraflame no dad
around yet a Duraflame and boom have one
of those we were back at Sue's place we
see me somebody first thing I got my mom
sounds like oh I'm gonna put a fire on
Chico okay at best awesome I too want it
to this day one of my favorite things to
do at the holidays is turn off all the
lights just the Christmas lights stay on
and watch movies like yeah I LaBeouf's
the tree in the light Christmas well
let's get back we keep interrupting your
ground this is awesome I'm feeling your
best we see right now it just happened
that's how the Christmas spirit gets you
guys you can't plan don't try and get
away here and i feel it i just write it
is here okay so no money your little kid
the only way you can get things you want
your birthday and Christmas thank God I
was a summer baby okay spread out
equally around the year now there's a
lot of things I want there's a lot of
stuff on the line mm-hmm Santa Claus
taught you one major lesson good
behavior gets rewarded bad behavior gets
punished but you don't know that
Christmas mornings your report card you
could be looking at a stocking full coal
I really thought that was a legitimate
option
yeah I know it was always the threat
yeah and the closer I got the Christmas
the more perfect i would start trying to
notice in the [ __ ] fireplace when I
have a dad the door flames burn aloma
but you remember that when you were a
kid you like luck you remember stuff
like pushing a kid off his bike like an
August joy but now wonder if that caught
one gift right every big game sulis
thanksgiving comes on like moms you need
any help let me scrub the floors I can
do those dishes I'll take out the trash
you're trying to be perfect a more
closer you get to the big day the more
you're trying to stock up good point
it's funny you say that because my
stepson this is a few years ago was like
the night before Christmas Christmas Eve
some people call it and uh he just
pissed her off he did something got her
all mad and then he was then you could
see it registering like oh like that
might cost me so he was microwaving
something and he used to tell him don't
stand in front of microwave could get
radiation or whatever so he puts up in
the microwave stood next to it with his
back up against the wall just look at me
Mom I'm not standing in front of the
microwave I was [ __ ] pissing myself
because that was his correction for what
he had just done wrong if he wasn't
steady his back like look at me I'm not
of it all dude I was dying like look at
this kid tried his ass all to make sure
he gets those gifts oh that's so perfect
that's exactly what I'm talking about
yeah I remember that night now we're
getting ready and this is all before elf
on the shelf you know I know we had that
same elf but we never had it we had the
elf but it wasn't a gaint you did it was
like I [ __ ] SAT there neither they
move around like been delayed my
grandmother say they have elbow they
sell it as elf on the shelf he sits
there and watches you and you move it
around and all I get crazy with it we
put it like what you do is yet you put
it like in your kids like next to him in
when he wakes up it's like right there
face to face of them I wanted to know
that's all other story all right come on
I want to hear let's finish this why are
we keep interrupting or like little
footage I know they're saying that right
now so it's Christmas Eve I'm feeling
the pressure okay that's my point I
remember going what we don't have
cookies we got Santa's going to show up
and there's going to be no cookies
my average you leave cookie did you
leave food out for reindeers too yeah
had to wear it we are with that once in
a while we do a carrot but not every
year you're not but you don't forget to
care yeah they might leave something
extra Rudolph will be like let's go come
on glass of milk cookies care yeah but
then my amer my dad was like I thinks
adamite what some pepperoni instead some
cheese yes already cheesesteaks her
there like he would have a Santa hoagie
alright anyways so I can't get to sleep
that night there's all the anticipation
and me my younger brother the three of
us were all in one room in the house
before now there's two of us in a room
and we're doing the talk back and forth
what do you want what do you think
you're gonna get there's three of you in
the room you said used to be this is a
new house so now it's just me and my
younger brother talking and then he
falls asleep mid conversation so now I'm
just alone with my thoughts that's
making it worse and now I'm going what
time is it I gotta get to sleep what if
Santa doesn't show up because he checks
and he's like Stevie ruined it you're
owned it for you you ruined it from mark
that's your point Chris never thought if
one of us is awake I hold for the whole
family and you know I me and then it's a
it's like that race car thing like don't
stare at the wall you don't hit the wall
don't hit the wall boom hit at all Mike
gotta fall asleep don't stay awake don't
stay awake now Mike I gotta stay awake
so then my big brother was feared but I
did it I walked over to his room I
knocked on his door Mike Chris I can't
sleep he's like get any how much older
is in three years so I'm like okay can I
sleep now does he still believe in
saying at this point no no he does for
Steve's case really yeah as far as I
know but he used to manipulate things
he'd be like look you know I got a
pipeline of Santa so go clean my room
that's really was i always think here on
our house like a corrupt union official
it was like the Tuesday everything's
gonna be fine as long as I get the wet
little awful like over my grandmother's
house she give us each a dollar mama
I'll hold on to it for the little ice
they're gonna live it up even there yeah
and then we never saw ruin so uh I get
in the bed and we're talking he's like
dude you gotta relax then I don't know
how long this conversation goes on for
but then he taps out and I pretended to
be asleep I don't like I'm not asleep
and I'm like if you just pretend to be
asleep you'll fall asleep nothing so now
its middle the night I'm going holy crap
Sam is gonna get here he's just up there
circling like this little [ __ ]
exactly i'm thinking like he's looking
for this is janna we're looking for a
run I heard it I don't know what time of
night it was I don't know what it was
but I heard on the roof and I heard
reindeer I heard it I never gone this is
there 32 hooves yeah I'm bro I'm like I
gotta fall asleep now now he's gonna
come down because I thought Santa kid
before he bought the gifts he swept the
house I get security detail yeah this is
gone bottle window Logan yeah yeah
checking the rooms putting a mirror
under your nose alive sleeping good and
then I just remember that number or
night please God let me fall asleep I
don't want to ruin Christmas so there's
reindeer on the roof road and you're
like home oh and the bells and
everything I'm like it you hurry to go
in my brain I did I know I could pass a
polygraph I look kids are great and then
I just remembered then I hear that I'm
like squeezing my eyes and fists
together like fall asleep fall asleep
and the next thing I remember is my
little brother opening his door going
santa came sinica oh you did for ya I
must have fallen asleep least for a
little bit because mark was the scout
team you'd always go down he checked
from the top of the steps like he's
looking down the valley like look at all
those guess that's my pile I know that's
my pie look that's what I wanted I'm
like did you go down no I didn't go down
there yet and then my big brother be
like guys relax we gotta go get mama
daddy's why sinica chat again and then
was Christmas magic that's awesome it
was great I know you really think you
could pass a polygraph yeah I heard it I
heard it and then sometimes I go was it
like my parents getting gifts out of the
attic or some right that that I heard
but whatever i heard it was real my
brother and I we also shared a room
there was one this was the house before
everything went bad it was so great
would you know fireplace we had a
wood-burning stove down there it was
perfect for Christmas and we swore we
were up to like one o'clock in the
morning we could not fall asleep
and then we looked out the window we
just saw this little red light and you
know it was probably who knows this was
probably Mars plane crash and we're
[ __ ] thinking it's as goddamn Rudolph
we are panicked and we're like just
getting back now that's Rudolph like and
we just kept listening and listening
then yet then you just fall asleep you
just fall asleep you wake up and there
it all is I think my favorite thing in
the history of life I know if you guys
ever did this but the nap underneath the
Christmas tree after you open love you a
dog yeah I never did Steve I would open
and just like this I'm work I just want
to go yeah I love the tree so much I
just wanted to be as close to it as
possible you wanna know the weirdest
thing that anyway ever had saw sweet
great it is that's it that's the name of
the third album sweeten crazy my best
friend growing up Dave George uh his
family every Christmas morning everyone
opened their gifts and I would always go
over to his house like in the afternoon
or that night you know and go like go
swing by the house they wouldn't open
their gifts and then everyone would
leave the gifts opened and like
presented underneath the table like if
you got a sweater the bot it would be in
the box with the wrapping folded I
various everything would be presented
under the you come by and they go look
at what you gettin all over here look
like it like you know it you look over
yeah that is hilarious Lecrae doing all
right over at the George has mine look
at this what Santa left everybody's
doing great that's the suburbs that's so
depressing cuz it's like everybody just
wants to kind of figure out how much
money everybody else has and everybody's
trying to bury each other a little bit
you'd love this to everyone yet Oh every
saturday morning in danger George's
house they would get donut maker donuts
everyone in my town would get dunkin
donuts there were four dunkin donuts in
my town the Georges for some reason went
to donut maker nobody went to donut
maker went the other way if you went
there on sat morning there'd be two
dozen donuts always next to the fridge
and like Dave's parents would always get
them but his grandparents would come
over all time and his grandfather would
always put a twenty-dollar bill
underneath him like let me pay for the
donor and I tell Dave all time I'm like
God you know you see my favorite thing
over your house is what I'm like
say morning's like yeah the Dons I'm
like now snagging that 20 the puppies to
leave I never did Steve that I was like
Santa wouldn't come yeah Santa would
definitely not calm and did you have
like a big household did everyone
grandmom grandpops come over when I was
Ted my grandmother moved in with us Oh
real in that house yeah she moved in
timid and want to see my mom is mom
lived with us too at first she had her
own little den she had her own bedroom
with a bathroom in an upstairs that's
nice she was the one that spoke Italian
to her sister only in Italian they would
talk I know she was talking mad [ __ ]
about everybody that house in the time
if we did another had a [ __ ] word
that goes ever she wanted uh so what
what was it health was it what happened
is your mom's mom was my dad's mom uh
would you like that oh yeah there's
nothing better than grandma my favorite
thing ever Graham but then she be with
your teeth it's a but you think you
think sleeping under a Christmas tree
was crazy then we already had two dogs
in our house it's not a big house we had
bandit in Adrian but then my grandmother
moves in and in her little room she kept
this sounds crazy but two miniature
schnauzers it was chaos and they
couldn't leave the room no they would
just pretty much hang out in there and
then she hang out with him outside and
take him for walks and stuff and how
long does she live with you years and
amber wants like when she had just moved
in she's still there and some say she's
still there hahahahaha the campfire
story and I say they're right remember
Bill Murray and meatballs labels the
hook out but I remember having a
sleepover when I was like ten and I was
like gosh you want to meet Graham she's
the coolest hey how are you sweetheart
that's all she talk slick rates and uh
when you're a little kid we know when I
did sleepovers I don't know if you guys
did it but we never went upstairs like
there was no the fun of a sleepover was
making forts out of the couch blankets
slip watching TV as late as you can stay
up sneaking out with toilet paper or
bottlerock always sneaking out Nico is
right bottle rockets toilet paper eggs
yes tehe fun shaving cream shaving cream
all that stuff so we're just we're ten
your little boys and that's all we're
trying to do but I remember this one
time vividly my buddy I'll Savio's been
like Steve you got away come from like
what is I don't think something's wrong
with your grandmother and yet it's here
this the other room way hey more like
what is it man she does here jump up she
goes Hotspur some [ __ ] spasms were like
what and that was like dad craft a
carpet can you scream yeah then he's
come down the steps and there was no
heart attack she just eaten a lot of ice
cream that night and had hearts PES i
think it was like heartburn or something
but i woke up all the kids have to sleep
over there all trauma traumatized
lactose intolerant had a heart at my
buddy Sandra's dad was an Italian guy
and off the boat and he used to just
fake heart attacks all time like if
signer was plotting something like he
just go on the stairs like Assad
thorough you give me a hug okay yeah he
would like fall down the stairs and
stuff and like it's like Craig still
affirmed like Jesus Christ solder he
dies like he's fakin do he does this all
the time dad just like nothing stair
lion that I remember on a field trip
once in fifth grade mrs. babitch is
class I had perfected I think you'd what
are you okay maybe I'm having a déjà vu
but my move was soon as I realized that
you could do that fake hitting your head
thing you put the hand in front of it
that was my patented move and we did a
field trip at the Museum of Natural
History in Philadelphia and and i
remember it was like a big deal and I
would just wanted attention and laughs
because I was the middle child and I did
it good in the middle of the line we're
one of the chaperones like wow right so
then everybody gathered around me and I
had to go with it I cuz I was like oh
this legs gone too far you're down on
the ground yeah and they just bought it
there like you want to sit down there
bring me like a dicks the wax Dixie cup
filled for the water fountain just
holding it my mom was on the trip she
was like are you fakin I I don't
remember if i've said this before on
there but uh practical jokes we used to
do as a head thing so back when I worked
did way back when I first got into LA
and I worked at ABC Family actually I
was a runner and then I got promoted
today he goes again
I got haha look at him going by I got
promoted to producer and I was sharing
an office with this guy and when he and
I got along awesome and then our boss
had the next office over but it was
attached okay but he was by himself so
we were gonna play this practical joke
on him where we were going to act like
he fell cut his face and he's bleeding
and we need to get we need to get him
some head okay so we had to catch a
packet and we had it already torn and we
just set it on the ground so we're like
all right we're walking through every
point now are you guys we're the slide
20 late 20s 48 maybe get a producer job
in 14 I mean about a movie earlier i
should add a producer job at a younger
age but i didn't get here tells like 27
so 28 yeah 28-29 maybe almost 30 years
and our desks face each other so I'm
like here's what we do I'll sit at my
desk you come in quickly like you're in
a hurry about something act like your
trip take the hand to the head bang on
the corner of the desk you fall down
here catch a package hidden out of sight
you quickly put that on your head we'll
be golden will [ __ ] with him because he
was that our boss was so nice and such a
pacifist and just you know common love
for everyone we're gonna roll this
[ __ ] up and it worked but it
also backfired backfired so what
happened was at the same time we're
doing this another guy unexpectedly
comes in the office and I can't tell him
like hey do you know for it there's a
dude awake with me guys I was like yeah
no yeah I'm like a bank I it was so
quick you're like wait what yeah who's
walking in the there's an off-duty cop
walking into the menu would come in from
acts exactly you would come in from the
outside it was one of those offices that
was like a little almost like in a strip
mall you know that type thing and he
comes in barrel and I'm trying to look
at him and before he can even see that
guy perfect trips BAM it looks so good
and he goes down and I'm now I'm
laughing because the other guys not
supposed to be in here
what the [ __ ] funny about that Jesus
Christ on my friend name is Jared he
goes with it he put the catch him on and
he comes up and then start to freak it
out he's like never forget to this day
he held two words he was he's cut god
that's what he kept screaming Russians
been come he's like iron he's screaming
he is cuts all he could say is he's
apparently he's freaked out about blood
to which I had a bonus that I forget
about some people don't like the sight
of ba he's got ketchup all over his
forehead it smells like ketchup he's
screaming he's cut to anyone to listen
everyone starts running in I'm pissing
myself and they're screaming at me
because I'm laughing at this guy that
just so [ __ ] happy to G and then
finally he gets up he's like sorry man
is a practical joke that wasn't meant
for you it was for the other guy that
you just called it and he panicked man
he [ __ ] himself but it weren't is he mad
yes oh he wasn't mad after that no he
was mad at me at the time I couldn't
even talk i'm laughing like I get what I
can't breathe I'm trying to tell him
like this is not and I just couldn't get
it out and he's just like it's not
[ __ ] funny but he wanted to deal with
this guy first make sure he's okay then
yell at me and then once he found out
was a joke he died laughs and he loved
it he's [ __ ] ice cream he's cut splice
he's good that's just that's your next
t-shirt he's gonna lie that right now
got a brand new shirt I've called all
juco right now get it on I'm fine that's
awesome Chuck oh I was gonna say that
just reminded me did you guys do this
when you're a little if there was
company coming over the house like I'd
feel like the need to either entertain
them yes or maybe make them victims of a
prank yeah let's take a spider and put
in front of mom that sort of thing
that's what it sounds like your boss had
a buddy come over I would do that I grab
my name is wigs and I come rocking out
in one of her wigs like what's up layers
which do wigs all time the bath I have
pictures of Wilson wigs along great
cross dressing and [ __ ] with her clothes
no one said a word about it like doesn't
curve was a simpler time do you ever do
this go hiding like find the halloween
masks like him august and they just see
more than halloween masks
we had bags like which mask yeah yeah
just way more fun they were they like a
rubber and you breathe in and get all
wet yes wedding in there yeah did so
much fun well you were saying we were
talking about pranks and you said there
was a pretty good one that uh yeah well
you guys were telling me a like because
your buddies and hang out have laughs
and everyone's going like the pressure
buddies buttons and this story I
remember this it was also real moving
out to LA it's it's it's near impossible
but there's something magical about it
at the same time and I was a kid that
grew up loving comedy like you talked to
I remember watching prior and eddie
murphy and i remember watching delirious
and then i remember the first time and
that was like a family celebration but
the first time comedy became like cool
with like my peers like dude did you see
that was andrew dice clay and I remember
like it was around the time like NWA
started to break dice and parental
warnings on tape right two more yeah and
then you were like cool if you're like
no dude I heard that I saw what you saw
faces of death yeah yeah yeah I heard
dices album dice has an album and then I
remember like people blasting it from
car so he was like a huge comic I when I
was 15 or 16 I bought tickets at the
philly spectrum the seed ice literally
touched the rafters I was second row
from the very last seat touch me old
flyer banners yeah yeah it's gonna roll
it up so you can see from up there
pushing the mo cheeks banner on my
sister ship it's all banner out of the
way I got them so then I moved out here
I got a job at The Comedy Store and one
thing later he becomes like my buddy
like my good friend yeah like you tell
him that you had seen him a number yay
loved and uh the thing about andrew is
that he's number one a world-class
family man like i under the first time
getting invited over to his house in
like he just lives like normal people
and he would like invite us over for
barter munoz i would see him in the
ralphs and sherman oaks all the time
yeah he's a normal dude yeah this was
back okay he lived in Beverly Hills at
the time the house was ridiculous but on
the inside was normal just family let
laughs and all that stuff now I would
manage the comedy store at night then
the next morning he would call me and
come pick me up at like ten in the
morning we'd go do runyon canyon and go
lift weights or go do something right it
was the best like me and dice are
becoming best friends and it was like I
said so really come that way and it's
like jumping in your TV set so there's
there's a Hollywood High School it's a
real place yeah Hollywood on Hollywood
have Indian something like that there's
like a mouse maybe a John Ritter painted
on the side another comedic hero of mine
island and sunset yes so we're trying to
get in the shape we would go hiking we
lift weights and ice like now we're
gonna do some track work or whatever I
know Mike what are you talking about
it's like it's different than a
treadmill it's better for you like one
that there's so many stores so we have
to break into the high school no Michael
is it a weekend or something I don't
even know I don't remember man I don't
know if skipper no no I remember but I
remember just like a 10-foot wire fence
he's hopping over and there's all these
put I'm like I'm not gonna break the
wall I'm not that's breaking it means
like come on for me for a goof and I'm
like uh-oh got a cigarette in his mouth
yeah he was like the bad kid influencing
me why I've never done of course
anything all right so he does it and I'm
like that moment of truth like should I
I'm about to do something bad i'm gonna
break in but i'm like no you gotta do it
he's your friend you wanna peer pressure
as it grown up so i said the top of the
philly spectrum and watch this guy right
yeah so I hop over get over the fence
and he's nowhere to be seen nowhere to
be seen I he hopped over I followed 30
seconds later and he's gone and I'm
looking around and I'm like how did I
get here it felt like a moment of
clarity I'm like I'm in Hollywood I bet
in Hollywood High School on an empty
track and then it dawns on me I'm like
I've completely lost my mind i Fight
Club the whole relationship with Andrew
Dice Clay and this is um that's honestly
and I'm going I am completely crazy I
need to go get help there's no way I
became friends with dice I can't how did
I wind up in California I gotta go back
to philly get to work I'm a crazy person
I'm looking
all over and I'm like that's it just
look for the gate and get figure out
where you parked and get now out of here
and then with this dice falls out of the
bushes laughing on the ground dying
laughing he's like oh you should have
seen your face oh you're faced with
places you went from excitement to fear
to resignation what were you thinking I
go Andrew I was thinking I and I got so
crazy that I invented my friendship with
you ah he's wiping tears from his eyes
to the bus let's go to starbucks I'm
gonna get frappuccinos [ __ ] running oh
my god so crazy and that's not the and
then I when I started to think of that
story that's not the most embarrassing
celebrity run and I had since moving out
here I remember years later at my lowest
point you know the city will beat you up
yeah no worse to be uh oh do i'm living
with fat James God rest his soul we're
sharing a little who was a recently
divorced 300-pound X Elvis impersonator
we're sharing a one-bedroom apartment in
Hollywood I'm so poor I don't have a car
have nothing I'm working two three
full-time like full-time part but
minimum wage jobs like I'd wake up do
telemarketing go work at a pizza place
then go work at The Comedy Store at
night no days off no stage time no days
off no time to create nothing it's just
miserable were all miserable and my
birthday was coming up and I remember my
younger brother who I love he's my best
friend than the smartest guy I know it
was like I'm gonna send you something
awesome for your birthday it's going to
change your life and he's a dentist so
I'm like what if he just sends me a box
full of cash that would be great a box
Bullock bah i'm pleased i'm a giant
chonnam all acting bit and then I've
dollar toothbrushes would have come in
handy back then come I can't get him for
Freeman brother did you remember when
you leave the book I remember going to
the dollar store and being like I wish I
could get it all he did all this [ __ ]
yeah you're like I only got seven bucks
spend it wisely you and one of the
things I did wind up buying in the
dollar store was uh because was right
around the time ipod started to come out
mp3 players you look like a dork at the
gym if you had those sony walkman with
the tape I'm like I can't rock this and
pick up chicks so I saw at the dollar
store these 99-cent
I don't know if anybody remembers but
their little squares and they were just
radius but they looked like an mp3
player before Apple took over the game
of ipods so I got one of those four
tunes all right my birthday finally
comes and checking every day with my
Russian landlady like did a big box come
that's it cuz now i'm taking my younger
brother's gonna send me supplies to make
t-shirts cuz i always had ideas for
t-shirts i'm like he's gonna bankroll my
business right so I'm expecting a giant
like refrigerator size boxes something
awesome like the dad in A Christmas
Story like where's my prize where's my
prize box finally comes it's the size of
a shoebox I'm like what's in here and
that's when I had the cash idea it
didn't occur to me to that and I go oh
my god it's going to be just money or
something in it and I open up the box
and it's tony robbins cds it's all true
and it was like dude i wish i could help
you more but i think you need this I
can't help you maybe Tony can do it
right so I was at such a low point that
I'm like I gotta try I gotta try it this
is where I am and I need help yeah did
whatever I'm doing is not working so I
got into it I did it and I remember one
of the things Tony Robbins said you have
to do is start your day with exercise
that's it don't even think keep your
sneakers right next to your bed soon as
your eyes open up roll out of bed put on
your shoes start walking because before
you know it you're awake you're not
going to stay in bed trying to analyze
do this he's like just start get moving
hour of power and then to positive
affirmations and breathing exercises so
I live down the street from the
Hollywood gym right down the street from
Hollywood High School it's a 24 hour gym
and the third floor was a VIP was a
boxing gym but a lot of VIPs worked out
there right you would hear rumors like
Matt Damon coming all I used to box at
that place um I nobody on uh tere tere
oh yeah you know one of terri's most
famous client Matt Damon Denzel role
very much I stays you know one why we've
the nicest guy in the world right super
nice he trains Matt Damon for all the
bourne movies yeah he's blown up yes
he's the real deal yeah box with him for
a while trained on you know training
what would it be at that jet at that gym
on the third floor up there yeah I i I'd
wound up getting a job there so that you
know the exact of my exactly all right
so I lived with fat James up on
Hollywood and fuller I'd walk down there
I'm already moving by the time I get to
the gym I'm in a good mood and I go
upstairs second floor to the treadmills
and that's it that would be my workout
go to if I could come back later in the
afternoon and grab a better workout but
this how i would start my day before i
do my telemarketing job now six o'clock
in the morning i'm at the gym I've been
at The Comedy Store to like one or two
but four hours sleep that's all i would
need I had always heard the rumor about
Denzel now I'm starting to show up and I
see Denzel that's when he worked out at
six in the morning all the winners I've
always noticed my life winners start
their day at the gym you want to change
your life wake up and exercise all the
winners so Denzel and would get to the
point where I knew the people that work
there I don't know i don't think i was
working there at the time but they knew
me and then I remember like talking to
like the kid behind the desk and then
like Denzel would come in and then I
just be standing I part of it now it's
getting to the point after months Denzel
was like hey champ and would hit me with
the fist oh yeah yeah haha alright so
now we're here yeah Oh bro so now I mean
I'm loving life my life's getting better
I my little eye mp3 player favorite
radio now I'm losing the girls in the
moon nobody nobody's in jail and uh and
I go up and I'm on one of the treadmills
and two away nobody else is in there
Denzel Washington to me are the only two
people on the treadmills right but we're
at the point where i can at least give
him a nod like acknowledge him as a
friend not like a creep like hey you're
the biggest movie star in the world all
right so he's on his treadmill on my
mind I'm going through my songs I loved
old st. elsewhere playa I look I grew up
in Philly I'm not familiar with country
music okay I don't know I didn't grow up
with it I love it now I just saw
Sturgill Simpson the guys call he's the
greatest hello but I didn't okay I hear
that you know that country guitar that
Brant Brown how a lot yeah it's so dope
right the name of the song i'm listening
to it the name of the song this is 12
years ago something like that was called
remember when by alan jackson mm-hmm
it's a very sad song Elise Agathe got me
I was in an emotional time was I you
know I'm dealing with it and I remember
I'm like it's I'm feeling it but I'm
like you can't cry in front of Denzel
Washington that you about to say that
you were his inspiration for glory when
he cried that went hero I'm holding it
in then there's a
fine in the song that goes like this and
the sound of little feet was music like
oh my god oh I don't cry but I make this
sale they go hmm like that like I'm
holding it in and Denzel looks looks
over he goes hey man are you all right I
go yeah I'm just listening to country
music what happened do that together you
gotta be careful shut up he'll do that
do you yeah every careful man I just cry
just tried in front of the hurricane I
wish you had more job the toughest guy
in Hollywood Oh call me all me he's over
there crying I charvel night buddy loved
it like it'll be all right he loved it
horsey good good times did you see more
than that or that I would see him after
that say oh man david alan grier I would
see him coming a lot to dag he was a he
work with him in there to everybody
meant yeah they all would um you were
also telling us before we started that
you were you were on a TV show Oh what
was the what dear tell us the size I
don't know anything about this one yeah
boy all right well now well it's not
worth any worse than crying in front of
Denzel Washington can't be all right so
my first job out here I mean I you talk
about crazy sleeping under the Christmas
tree dude I drove out here not really
knowing anybody no money no credit card
nothing me too i just showed up like a
crazy person just showed up and I
remember driving across country back
when Triple A would give you the trip
tix of the maps before yeah and I was
like I'm in Texas it's closer to get to
California that it is the Philly and I'm
like I don't even know if my car will
make it back to fill what are you
driving I am driving a ford probe 1993
over
the war I I see the new Broncos that are
coming out my dream has always been to
own a Bronco but Ford screwed me so bad
on that probe I don't know if I could
ever give them my money again such a bad
car so it makes it to LA I'm in town for
like four days and I get a job I get a
job at the slice pizzeria at ninth and
wilshire they're like dude you want to
I'm like yes I want a job I get a job
delivering pizzas working the counter
now I'm trying to figure out open mics
I'm doing it so I move out and say
September this is now may I was living
with two strangers up on Berkeley I'm
living the nicest place I've lived in
yes I say Santa Monica's no joke oh dude
it was two levels of your up an area up
there yeah well this was like behind the
ski shop at like Santa Maria oh yeah
berkeley yep so my pediatrician is right
there really okay so I still goes to a
pediatrician I was up to my mom I would
still be there Josh nigro me five
obvious and seminars to of like I'm I
was like team you can even be like at a
moustache a hair on your balls can't be
coming anymore my god make me the kids
nervous so I'm staying at this place I
don't know my roommate that's like you
just figure it out and the guys hit the
pizza place for like our friends moving
out 600 bucks a month for the room I
don't mind I could barely make that and
when I take barely I mean barely so now
the lease is expired I don't have enough
I don't really haven't really made my
comedian friends yet I hadn't been out
here a year yet so I can't have other
roommates we've been were moving out
problem was my ford probe blown up on me
by that point so now it's just sitting
in the driveway of this apartment that
I'm no longer living in so I'm like I
got to get it out before it's gone
forever at the time i went from the
three bedroom place in Santa Monica to
moving into a section 8 apartment with
my good friend Steve easy do you guys
know who he is the comedian with
cerebral palsy and we would that was
also sharing a one-bedroom apartment was
tvz it was in such a bad neighborhood
that I remember every time I left the
front door i would literally here
the opening riff to guns and roses
welcome to the jungle because I felt
like axl getting a bus there was a
[ __ ] motel next door once there was
I'm not saying the bullets flew over my
head but out of the corner of my eye I
saw the muzzle fire damn on the walls as
we're cutting through and I don't behind
a car Steve easy didn't he wanted to get
hit I want to grab him it was like I
tried to kill myself six times yeah I
know it's like well that's a whole other
story it's a bad neighborhood so now I'm
in this bed I go from Santa Monica to
this awful section eight apartment
before Hollywood was gentrified as my
point I have to take like two or three
buses to get back to my old apartment to
go meet a tow truck to tow my car towed
my car to a mechanic that I can't afford
to pay because I have zero dollars I got
nothing literally so now I wait for the
guy he brings it to aamco they loop they
were such ripoff artists that the double
a all right that guy in this video the
guy that owned the one here went to jail
oh wow yeah he went to jail um so I got
nothing and I used to work at the slice
so it's about a two mile walk and I just
walked it I'm like you know what I know
they'll feed me at the very least i'll
get a slice of pizza out of this so I
walk down there of course they fed me
great guys it's up Jules uh and then if
the phone rings and my buddy Matt it's
like hey man you want to take a delivery
I'm like I don't have a car you guys
don't worry about it hop in my car just
walk it in and keep the tip how's that
sound I'm like okay so the delivery
isn't to a house it's to a motel I'm
like this is weird he's like to just run
it and he's got a live parking street I
run for the motel and I knocked on the
door and ice here it's open come on in
no dude it's the pizza guy he was a guy
yeah come on in i'm like dude you don't
know me it's the pizza guy 16 bucks the
guy who's come in and I open the door
and there's one of those illegal
operations going on there's a guy
getting cut open on an operating table
well what bro let me finish the story
again haha we're not allowed to be
startled yeah so I freeze I don't move
yeah no shirt or what
and he goes yeah yeah come on in come in
and bring the pizza over go 16 bucks now
there's two guys were gonna go buddy 16
I'm so like you know my life's enough
and he was getting a lacerated spleen
about I that I was like and I got you
know what forget it and I take the pizza
out and I put it on the tail like after
the day I've had this is the perfect way
to end it I put the bag oh forget it I
don't even walk into the room I just put
the pizza on the nearest table with just
extend my arm to put it on the thing you
know forget it and I leave and I'm
walking across the parking lot like it
now how how am I gonna explain to my
buddy that I own 16 bucks that I don't
have and now here comes a PA running
after me you're on spy TV I'm the last
by TV get back here and I'm like am I
music will you sign this release what I
should have done is not signed the
release because I could have gotten the
two or three grands I'm sure to pay for
my car because when that show turns out
Doug Stanhope was the doctor oh really
yeah but he had like a surgical mask on
Denzel was the patient no gonna do 60 so
it was first episode ever airs that
summer I was Emma's NM TV and NB c NB c
NB c ya never one of my first comm buzz
kill was mtv i put it as like a credit
was comical yeah you do have seen on spy
TV dude my phone is blowing up now I'm
in LA for about a year I'm get it trying
to hustle stage time whatever and
everybody said haha you didn't make cuz
philly people are mean I you moving to
make no I you moved out there that
deliver pizzas you got punked at it and
I'm like what are you talking about I go
I paid to do I'm just a good actor
they're like you are a good actor it was
the birthday yeah it's the first episode
ever and I they said I was the only one
that was smart enough not to go in the
room everyone else would go in they said
there was people helping the guy do the
surgery self and stand up they got paid
big money those guys searchable do you
even learn how this
crazy so now guy that I'm saying is it's
been 16 years of these struggles please
support me by buying buying a copy my CD
would you help me out I'm trying to make
a living over hey what can a guy do why
do you say you could have made 3 grand
if you held out yeah I think so yeah cuz
they loved it and they were like you
that was the best and they it was they
use it as their first prank ever first
show first thing yet is that still
exists somewhere oh sure as I haven't
seen it in six idea what you haven't
even bothered look on youtube updates on
their site EVP to elyria yeah I don't I
don't ever look at stuff I've done I can
i get i can't stuff I've done no no no I
mean anything but it's the loser credit
now I don't mean like that but like even
like ever like here I it's difficult for
me to still eat I'm always this is not
happening i won't even look I've watched
it one time to approve what they were
gonna put on I won't [ __ ] watch it
yeah yeah it's just I hate watching
myself yeah there's no one no I don't
care who you think you are out there
hiding behind your keyboard [ __ ] on
people there's no one that's more
critical of me than me correct there's
nothing you are going to say that you
know related to it not just like oh
you're [ __ ] out or whatever right
that that I've noticed everything that's
that's right that's right yeah and I'm
getting better at that like that was I
don't know you guys would bring me on
around this time here whenever we talk
about new year's resolutions and stuff
this is I've been getting better at
living where I'm like you know what you
got to be better to yourself be is nice
to yourself as you would be to a
stranger yeah it'd be kinder to yourself
that's all that matters we're seeing you
seeing somebody now late lady friends
yeah yeah I keep saying some pictures
out there you look happy and I'm happy
for you yeah but she keeps talking like
babe can we just have our own private
yeah I know right they love to put those
[ __ ] oh my god and its work I realized
on the drive over here movies made Vegas
high school and relationships seem so
much more fun oh god yeah right oh it's
work and I love her but it's like oh my
god well this has been a lot of fun man
we love you we love having you on thank
you so much for coming back thank you
guys i hope it was good no great mates
always thought we'll see we'll listen to
i mean the fence
we're wrong we're wrong uh will you one
more time please promote your CD your
social media podcast all of it guys the
CD I'm very proud of it I can actually
listen to it go like this at finally the
stuff that I wanted to do took a long
time to get there but I tried to lose it
was tough it's called what's up nerds
it's it's available online you can buy a
physical copy that looks like a pizza
off of Awesome Steve calm and I have a
podcast good good times and by the time
this comes out I should be on our ease
this is not happening on Comedy Central
to as yours as an air do you know it's
December great great also make sure you
check that out and get over there and
support them throw some crab feast
comments up on there if you're not a
Steve Simone fan you should be you have
to foul down great to see you buddy
birthday love you too love you too but
as always Jay Larson call me calm Jay
Larson comedy on facebook twitter
instagram pinterest Ryan sitcom Ryan
Sickler on Twitter Instagram Ryan
Sickler official on facebook we'll talk
to you all next Tuesday